i apologize to take this in this
direction for a brief moment but i've
been really
deep on stalin and hitler recently
uh in terms of reading and is there
something
that you think about in terms of um the
nature of evil
from a neuroscience perspective is there
some lessons that are sort of um
hopeful about
human civilization that
we can find in our brain with regard to
the hitlers of the world
do you do you think about the nature of
evil
yeah i do i don't know that
what i have to say is so useful from a
i don't know that i can say as a
neuroscientist well here or here's a
study
that you know what i so i i sort of have
to take off my lab coat right
and now i'm going to now conjecture as a
human who just also
who has opinions but who also maybe has
some knowledge about
neuroscience but i'm not speaking as a
neuroscientist when i say this because i
don't think
neuroscientists know enough really to be
able to say but i guess
i the kinds of things i think about are
um
what so i have always thought
even before i i knew anything about
neuroscience
i've always thought that um
i don't think anybody could become
hitler but i think
the majority of people can be
can do are capable of doing very bad
things
um it's just the question is really how
much encouragement does it take from the
environment to get them to do something
bad
that's what i kind of when i look at the
life of hitler
it seems like there's so many places
where something could have intervened
interva no it changed completely the
person i mean there's like
the caricature like the obvious places
where he was an artist
and if he wasn't rejected as an artist
he was a reasonably good artist
so that that could have changed but just
his entire like where he
went in vienna and all these kinds of
things like little interactions could
have changed
and there's probably millions of other
people who are uh capable who the
environment
may be able to mold in the same way did
this particular person to create
this particular kind of charismatic
leader in this particular moment of time
absolutely and i guess the way i would
the way that i would say it i
i would agree 100 and i guess the way
that i would say it is like this
in the west we have a way of reasoning
um about causation
which focuses on single simple causes
for things
you know there's a there's an essence to
hitler there's an
essence to his character he was born
with that essence or it was
forged very very early in his life and
that explains the um
the landscape of his the horrible
landscape of his behavior
but there's another way to think about
it a way that actually is much more
consistent with what we know
about biology how biology works
um in the physical world and that is
that most things
are complex not as in wow this is really
complex and hard but
complex as in complexity that is more
than the sum of their parts
and that most phenomena have many
many weak non-linear interacting causes
and so little things that we might not
even be aware of
can shift someone's developmental
trajectory from this
to that and that's enough to take it on
a whole set of other paths that uh you
know that
and that these things are happening all
the time
so it's not random and it's not really
it's not deterministic in the sense that
like everything you do
determines your outcome but it's a
little more like
um you know you're nudging someone from
one set of possibilities to another set
of possibilities and i
but i think the the thing is the thing
that i find optimistic is that the
the other side of that coin is also true
right so look at all the people
who risk their lives to
help people they didn't even know
i mean i just watched borat the new
borat movie
and the thing that i came away with but
you know
the thing i came away with was look at
how
like generous people were in that
because he's making there are a lot of
people he makes fun of and
that's fine but think about like those
two guys
those those the the trump supporter guys
the trump supporter guys
those guys those kind there's kindness
in them right
they took a complete stranger
in a pandemic yeah into their house
who does that like that's a really nice
thing or
there's one scene i mean i want to spoil
it for people who haven't seen it but
but there's you know there's one scene
where he goes in he dresses up as a jew
i i laugh myself sick at that scene
seriously
but um but he goes in and he and there
are these two old jewish ladies
yeah what a bunch of sweethearts
oh my gosh like really yeah
i mean that was what i was struck by
actually i mean there are other ones or
or like
the babysitter right i mean she was
really kind and yeah so
that's really what i was more struck by
like you know
sure there are other people who you know
who who do
very bad things or say bad things or or
whatever but
you know or like there's one guy who's
completely stoic
like the guy at the um who's doing the
like you know sending the message i
don't know if it's
facts or whatever he's just completely
stoic but he's doing his job
actually you know like you can't you
don't know what he was thinking inside
his head you don't know what he's
feeling but he was totally professional
doing his job
okay so i guess i just i had a bit of a
different
um v you know view i guess and i so i
also think that about people i think
everybody is capable of kindness and um
but for but you know it's the question
is how much does it take and what are
the circumstances so for a lot some
people it's going to take a lot
and for some people it only takes a
little bit but
you know are we actually
cultivating um an environment for the
next generation
that um
[Music]
provides opportunities for people to go
in
the direction of caring and kindness or
you know and i'm not i'm not saying that
as like a you know pollyanna-ish
person um you know i think there's
a lot of room for competition and debate
and and so on
um but i don't see hitler as an anomaly
and i never have that that was even
before i learned anything about
neuroscience and now
i would say knowing what we know about
developmental trajectories and life
histories and how important that is
um you know knowing what we know about
um
that the whole question of like nature
versus nurture is a completely wrong
question
you know we have the kind of nature that
requires nurture
we have the kind of genes that allow
infants to be born with
unfinished brains where the brains their
brains are wired
across a 25-year period with wiring
instructions from the world that
is created for them and
so i don't think hitler is an anomaly
um you know even if it's even if it's
less probable that that would happen
it's
possible that it could happen again and
it's not
it's not like you know he's a bad seed i
mean that doesn't i just want to say
like of course he's completely 100
responsible for his actions and all the
bad things that happen so i'm not in any
way
this is not me saying but the
environment is also responsible in part
for creating the
evil in this world so like
hitler's and different versions of even
more subtle
more smaller scale versions of evil
you